- Hi, everyone, and thank you
for coming to this discussion
of grant and fellowship applications.
I'm Steve Pitti, professor
of history, American studies,
and ethnicity, race and migration,
and I direct Yale's Center
for the Study of Race,
Indigeneity and Transnational Migration.
I want to thank our staff,
Maggie Katz and Nicole Edwards,
for their help putting
this event together today.
This session is gonna focus on
identifying external and
internal opportunities
of interest to the RITM community,
on identifying application strategies
and the value of pursuing
those opportunities
for graduate and professional students.
I'm really grateful for the presence
of Dean Robert Harper-Mangels,
who has been a dean in
the Yale Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences since 2006.
He is currently associate dean
for admissions and
financial support at Yale.
In this position, he has
primary responsibility
for overseeing student fellowships
and external funding applications.
Dean Harper-Mangels has a
bachelor's degree in music
and psychology from Wesleyan University
and also a PhD in
neuroscience and behavior
from the University of
Massachusetts at Amherst.
Thank you so much, Dean Harper-Mangels,
for being here with us today,
really appreciate your willingness to come
and talk to us about applying for grants,
which I think is gonna be
of great use to all of us.
Thank you very much for being here today.
For those of you who are present,
please feel free to put
questions in the Q and A
and we'll try to get those
to Dean Harper-Mangels at the end.
Thanks.
- Thanks, Steve. Happy to be here today.
We're gonna talk about applying for grants
and the first thing that I
would like to address is,
actually, the first thing I'd
like to address is why my,
here we go, getting my
slides to move forward,
is why you should apply for grants.
A lot of students think that
they have a full fellowship,
they have six years of
funding while they're at Yale,
there's a lot of opportunities
to get a Yale funding
for travel and research,
so why should they spend the
time applying for these grants?
And the first thing I would say is
that this is a really
important career skill
for all of you to be
developing at this point.
When you think about applying for a grant,
what you're really doing
is promoting your work.
You're trying to get people excited
about the kinds of things
that you want to do
to the degree that they
would like to support it
in some way,
and this goes beyond just
getting grant funding
for the work that you're doing now.
If you think about applying for a job,
if you think about the kinds of careers
that you might have in the future,
you're often trying to sell people
on the work that you're doing
and getting them excited about
how they can support what you want to do.
This is a great skill to be developing
at this point in time,
when you have this safety
net, when you have a stipend,
when you have other forms
of support available
so that if you go out and you
don't get the fellowships,
it's okay.
We can still support you,
you can still do the
work that you need to do,
but this is a great time
to just start working on these skills.
One of the things you
wanna remember is that,
I like to say funding begets funding.
First of all, if you're
applying for a grant
and somebody is looking at your CV
and they're looking at your
background and seeing that,
"Oh, this person's been supported
by this agency to do this work.
They've been supported in the
past by this other agency.
They look like they're
good stewards of the money.
They look like when they say
they're gonna do something,
they get it done.
We feel better about
supporting this student too
because we think that they will do
what they say they're going to do,"
and it also gives you an opportunity,
a valuable opportunity to
establish a relationship
with funding agencies, so that,
and I use this example a lot
with my science students,
if you've applied to the NIH for a grant
as a pre-doctoral grant
and you are funded and you do the work
and you complete your PhD,
and then you go and you get a post-doc
and you apply for a post-doctoral grant
and they agree to support that,
then when you're a junior faculty member
and you're applying for
that first faculty grant,
they're gonna look and they're gonna say,
"We supported this person
when they were a pre-doc
and we supported this person
when they were a post-doc.
They've done what they
said they were going to do.
They've been successful throughout.
Let's continue to back this horse.
Let's continue to provide
support to this person.
They've been a good bet so far,
so we should keep on with them."
Establishing a relationship
with a funding agency
that might be useful to
you in your future work
is a good thing to do, and again,
now is the time to establish that,
and then there were just some
practical benefits to you
as a doctoral student.
The first, of course, is that
if you win an outside award,
whatever it is they're providing you with,
they'll provide you with a top-up
and bring you to the full stipend,
plus you'll get $4,000 above
the current stipend levels.
You'll make a little bit
more money, or alternatively,
if it's a travel award
and you want to go abroad
in a teaching year,
you obviously aren't going to be paid
if you're not teaching in,
say, your third or fourth year,
but that's why funding
gives you the flexibility
to buy out your teaching
or postpone your teaching
and support yourself while
you do field work in year four
so that you don't need to go
and use your dissertation fellowship,
which you'd really like to preserve
and have available to
you when you come back
so you do have that teaching-free year
that you can start writing in.
I just want to talk about a few things.
How do you get started?
If I've convinced you
that you should be applying for awards,
how do you start this process,
but what should you be looking to do?
Step one obviously is just
finding fellowships to apply for.
There's a database here at
Yale, at funding.yale.edu,
which mostly contains competitive awards
that are funded through Yale.
These are usually endowed
funds that are given to Yale
to support travel or
research in certain areas
that you would apply for
on a competitive basis,
but it's Yale's money.
It also would include fellowships
that for which some sort of a
Yale endorsement is required,
so that if there's, say,
a limited number of students
from Yale are permitted
to apply for some external fellowship
and we have to engage in some
sort of a nominating process,
you'll find most of those
on the Yale grants and funding page.
Grantforward.com is probably
the single best site that I've ever seen.
It's certainly not the
only site out there,
but it's a very comprehensive site.
It contains large awards, small awards,
federal awards, private awards.
I think I went in the other day
and typed in race and migration
and it came up with 3,000 results.
You will have to play
with it a little bit,
play with different keywords to focus in
on the things that are
most important to you,
but this is a site that Yale
is a sponsor of the site.
You should, from any Yale.edu address,
be able to log in and make use of it,
and you'll see everything in there,
from your large federal
$35,000 full-year awards
to $500 to support research
for people who are studying
the use of corn in society
and whose grandparents or
parents were born in Greece.
There are some very small,
very specific grants out there
and large federal awards out there.
GrantForward seems to have them all.
The grants.gov website is a
sort of a central clearing house
for most of the
federally-funded fellowships
that you might apply for,
and I would just urge you,
if you're looking into
travel awards to go abroad,
you should look also at
the country websites,
look to see if the country
itself has fellowships
to attract students to
come to the country.
Not everybody does,
but Germany and Japan have big agencies
that provide a lot of money for this.
There's the InterAmerican Foundation
that will fund travel to
Central and South America.
There's a lot of ways to find grants
that might be of interest to you,
and finally, make use of the
people in your department.
Ask your faculty. Ask
the most senior students.
Find out what the other
people have applied for
or what agencies they've been
involved with in the past
and see what they have to say.
If the most important message I have today
is that it's important for
you to apply for fellowships
at this stage of your career,
that it's great training for you,
that it's really good practice,
the second most important message I have
is that when you're
applying for a fellowship,
it's really critical
to understand the needs
and the motivation of the
agency that you're applying to.
There are lots of organizations
out there that have money
that they're willing to give
to you to promote your work,
but they all have a different
reason for doing it,
and it's all well and good to say,
"Well, I want to do this
and I'm interested in
that and if you fund me,
here are the things that
I'll be able to do,"
but does it speak to the
mission of the agency?
I'll just give you two quick examples.
I have students in the
sciences who will apply,
they work on a project and they'll apply
to both the NIH and the NSF.
The mission of the NIH is to cure disease
and relieve human suffering.
The NSF has that as a mission as well,
but the NSF also has more
of an educational outreach,
a science literacy
component to their mission,
so then you can't just
take the same project
and submit it to both agencies.
With the NIH it's really what
is it that I'm going to do
and how is this going to
lead to curing disease.
With the NSF it's what am I going to do
and how is it going to
cure disease, but also,
how is the training that
I'm going to receive
going to allow me to go out
and improve science literacy?
How am I going to share
the results of my work
with an audience beyond
the people in my lab
and the people in the scientific
community that I work with?
Another example is the Fulbright
and the Fulbright-Hays.
Fulbright is funded by
the Department of State
and it's a cultural exchange grant.
The Fulbright-Hays is funded
by the Department of Education
and it's really more of
a language and cultural literacy grant.
Again, you can have the same project
and apply to both agencies for funding,
but in the case of Fulbright
you really need to explain
how in the course of doing this project
it will promote cultural exchange.
These are where the opportunities
for cultural exchange will be.
Fulbright-Hays doesn't care
about cultural exchange
so much as they care
about the degree to which
you are becoming a knowledge expert
in the language and the
culture of that country.
They don't necessarily care
what you're giving back.
They want to know what you're getting
so that you can come
back to the United States
and be a resource to the US government
if they need to talk to somebody
about conditions in that country.
Same project but a different spin on it
so that you can speak to
the mission of the agency
and convince them that
they want to support you.
In understanding their mission,
you also want to think
about who at the agency
is going to be reading your application.
Are these PhD-level scientists
who work in your field?
If so, less explanation about
why you're doing what you're doing
or specifically what you're
doing may be appropriate.
You'll want to get into more
detail about the methodology
and maybe some of the
nuances about the work
that you'll be engaged in.
These may be PhD-level people
who are not in your field.
If you apply to Fulbright,
the Fulbright applications, for example,
are all reviewed by country.
The first round of review,
if you've applied to France
and you're interested in poetry
at the time of the Renaissance,
French poetry at the
time of the Renaissance,
the first people who are
going to read your application
are gonna be three PhD-level faculty
who studied France,
but one of them might
focus on medieval history,
one of them might be
interested in modern history,
and maybe one of them is
doing religious studies.
Educated people, yes, but not
necessarily in your field.
In that case,
you can't assume that
they'll understand everything
you're talking about right up front.
You need to provide a little more detail
about what it is you want to do,
why this is interesting,
why it's important,
what kind of gaps you're
filling in the knowledge
in that field.
I have a number of students
now who are applying to P.E.O.,
which is a woman's
organization which promotes,
provides funding for
women in higher education.
It's quite likely that the people
who will be reading those applications
may be doctors, lawyers, CEOs,
highly-educated people,
but not necessarily PhDs,
and certainly not people who
are working in the fields
that the students are applying in.
Just think about who your audience is
and what level of detail
you need to provide
in order to get them up to speed
on what it is you're studying
and why this is interesting.
You can't assume that just because
you think it's interesting,
that they're going to
think it's interesting
without you pointing them
to the different cues
that they would say, "Oh yeah, no.
Now that you've explained
it to me, this makes sense.
This does sound interesting."
Once you've identified
something you want to apply for
and you've thought about
the motivation of the agency
and providing the funding,
there's some other things you can do.
First of all, has anybody
else in your department
applied for this award in the past?
It may be that your registrar has access
to old applications.
It may be that some of the students
who have applied are still here
and you can talk to them
about their experience
and whether or not they
received any feedback
and have any insights into what works
or what doesn't work with an application.
Maybe some of your faculty have served
as reviewers for this organization
and they certainly then
would be a great resource
to tell you what the
reviewers are looking for.
If you're applying for
international travel,
the MacMillan Center is a great resource.
They've got knowledge experts there
who can talk to you about
what's going on in individual countries
and things that you
might need to think about
and problems that you
might need to address
in the application, pitfalls or problems
that you might need to overcome
that they can say that an
agency might want to see
that you're knowledgeable about.
The Graduate Writing Lab,
I want to say it's an
outstanding resource.
I have not sent anybody
there who's ever come back
and told me that it was
a waste of their time.
I've had a lot of people come back and say
that they were really very helpful.
They do a number of different things,
including peer review, writing groups,
one-on-one mentoring with tutors.
They're a fantastic resource
if you're applying for an award
where the people who are reviewing it
are not necessarily going
to be squarely in your field
because now you're talking
to an educated audience
that will say, "Yeah,
your writing is good,
this looks like a tight proposal,
but I'm not sure I really understand
what it is you're doing.
I think maybe you need to provide
a little more information just up front,
couple of sentences to help
orient the non-expert reader."
The Graduate Writing Lab can
be a great source for that
in a way that your advisor, for example,
might not be able to help you
because they do what you do
and they're going to
understand what you're doing.
They'll be filling in
any gaps that existed
in the writing in their own heads.
The Graduate Writing Lab
won't be able to do that.
They can ask you questions
and have you go back
and rewrite it and fill
in those gaps yourself.
In some cases,
the funding agencies may encourage you
to reach out to them
directly before applying,
and again, remember that they have money,
they're supporting some cause,
they want successful applicants,
so it's not always the case
they don't all have the
bandwidth to do this,
but many of them will actually
want you to reach out to them
and say, "Hey, this is
what I'm working on.
This is something I think would be
of interest to your agency.
Is this something that
would fly as a proposal?"
And they can give you feedback.
"Yeah, this sounds really interesting.
We'd be more likely to
fund this than that.
You might want to steer
it in this direction,"
but if they invite you to reach out,
I encourage you to do so.
You can get a lot of really
valuable bits of information
directly from them about
what they would consider
to be a successful application,
and I just want to add,
I'll have my contact information
at the end of these slides,
but you can certainly feel free
to reach out to me at any time.
I may not know about the specific award
that you're applying for,
but I do have quite a bit of experience
with a variety of fellowship applications
and I can certainly help you figure out
how to get the answers if
you can't get them yourself.
I'll talk a little bit
about some of the elements
that would go into an application,
and again, they're all different.
This is not going to apply
to every application,
but almost certainly there's gonna be
some sort of a research proposal,
just what it is that you want to do,
and very often a personal
statement and reference letters,
and I'll talk about
those each a little bit,
and then depending on the award,
they may want transcripts,
they may want a CV.
Some awards will ask
you to provide a budget
and sometimes there are
short answer essays,
essay prompts that they
might ask you to complete.
I'll just talk about each of these
in a little bit more detail.
The research proposal,
it's what you would expect.
What do you want to do and
why do you want to do it
and how do you plan to do it,
and it's surprising to me sometimes
how many people will start these essays
and not cover those three elements.
They sort of launch into
how they're going to do it
before they've really
explained what they want to do
and they never address
why they want to do it.
You really start big, and again,
the amount of space you spend on this
depends in part on the
application requirements.
Is this a two-page proposal?
Is it a 10-page proposal?
That gives you clues
to the level of detail
that they might be looking
for, and then, again,
thinking about the audience
that's reading this
and how expert they are in your field,
you want to provide some description of
this is what I'm interested in,
this is why I'm interested in doing this,
and then start to focus
in on what's the plan.
If you fund me, this is
what I'll be able to do,
this is how I'll go about doing it.
Obviously you'll want to talk about
what you gain from doing
this, and it's not just,
"Well, I'll be able to
complete my dissertation,"
but if your dissertation is
a four or five or six-year project
and you're asking for
funding to go to a country
for three months to gather data,
what specifically will you
gather while you're there?
How is this going to
inform your dissertation?
What piece of the overall whole
is this going to speak to?
Hopefully you can get it
to that level of detail,
and then of course,
what is the funding agency
going to gain from this?
How does my work advance your mission?
What do you get out of this?
And when you apply for a fellowship,
make sure you know if they're
expecting any deliverables.
In some cases, they're not.
They just expect you to go.
You do your work and
complete your dissertation,
but in other cases, they
expect a paper to be published
or they expect some sort of a report
or some sort of presentation.
Sometimes it's open-ended,
but they expect you to produce something.
Find out if they're
expecting a deliverable
and be sure to be up-front
about what it is you plan to do.
The Fulbright-Hays application
actually provides a
scoring sheet and it says
you get so many points for this
and so many points for that,
and one of the things that
they will score you on,
it's like 10 points for your plans
to share the results in your dissertation,
and I've had so many students
who have just missed the
cutoff for getting the grant
because they never really said
anywhere in the application
how they were gonna share the results
from their dissertation,
and they've said to me,
"Well, I'm gonna write my dissertation
and then it's gonna go into the library
and it will be publicly available."
It's like, that's fine,
but you never said that,
and so the reviewers docked you 10 points
because you didn't say how you
were gonna share your results
and you missed the cutoff
and there's no appeals.
Make sure you understand
what they're looking for
and make sure you address
those things in the proposal,
and again, I can't say it enough,
just think about the audience.
Who's reading this? What level
of knowledge do they have?
Think about the level of detail
that you need to provide,
the rationale for why you're doing this,
and the methods that you're going to use
to get the work done.
If they have a separate
personal statement,
hopefully, first of all,
the agency has provided information about
what they would like to
see in a personal statement
so that it will be tailored to the needs
of the funding agency,
but that's not always the case.
Sometimes they will say,
"And please provide a
one-page personal statement,"
and you're left to guess
what they're looking for.
Usually it's good to think about this as
it's a description of the
experiences you've had,
the professional and
educational experiences,
maybe the personal experiences,
that have led you to this moment.
You've explained in the research proposal
what it is you want to study.
How did you get here? How
did you come onto this topic?
What are the things that have
motivated you to do this work
and what are the experiences
that have prepared you to do this work?
It's often the case that if
they're going to fund you,
they want to see that
this is not just something
that you're doing for six months
and then you're gonna go
off and do something else.
They want to see a journey
and that there's a
motivation to do this work
and that if they fund you to do this,
that this is an investment
that's going to pay
dividends down the road,
that you're going to continue
to do this kind of work,
that you really have a passion
for what it is you're trying to pursue,
and that we'll fund you now
and this will help advance your career
and then you'll continue
to do these sorts of things
and that will promote our mission as well,
and one of the things
that can be very helpful
in the personal statement
is any solid examples that you can provide
of the kinds of skills or competencies
that you would need to carry out the work.
There's a lot of people who like to say,
"Oh, I'm a real leader,"
or, "I'm very adaptable
and if the situation
on the ground changes,
I'll be able to roll
with the circumstances
and make some changes."
That's all well and good to say,
but if you can provide
examples of a time in the past
when you've actually had to adapt
or when you've shown those
leadership qualities,
that's golden, that's really
what they're looking for,
and it doesn't need to be a
comprehensive list of examples.
Even one solid example can go really far
and can put you ahead of people who say,
they say they can do this,
but have they ever done it in the past?
Providing examples of things
that would be important
to the funding agency is good,
and just as you want to
talk about your motivation
to do this work and how you came to this,
something about your career
aspirations or the next step
or where you're going to go from here.
After you fund me to do
this and I do X, Y and Z,
where am I going to take this?
Again, it's not true of every agency,
but a lot of them are going to want to see
that whatever it is
they're funding you to do
is a path on a journey.
It's a piece of the puzzle.
They want to see where you're coming from,
they want to see where you're going to,
and they want to see how
this funded experience
is going to fit into
that larger trajectory.
You've all had references.
You had to get three to
get into graduate school,
so you've all done this before.
I think the biggest
question I get from people
is things like,
"Gee, I feel like I should have my advisor
write a letter for me,
but I've only started
working with the advisor
two or three months ago.
They don't know me that well.
Certainly they can talk about
the importance of my work,
but they don't know me personally
and they can't say a lot of things
and they certainly don't
know anything about my past."
Most, again, not all,
but most of these applications
are going to let you submit
more than one reference, usually three.
That's typical.
You should think about it
in terms of between them,
the three referees should
be able to speak about
various aspects of your character.
Usually the funding agency wants to know
that the work that you're proposing to do
is in fact important,
that it's going to advance
the field in some way
or fill in some gap in
knowledge in the field.
They want to know that
you have the ability
to carry out the work.
It's one thing to show
us something, and yes,
this is very exciting and
we're really enthused by this,
but are you the person to do it?
Are you actually
qualified to do this work?
Reinforcing what I said
about the personal statement,
what is your motivation to do this?
And often information about
what kind of support is available to you,
not financial support so
much as intellectual support.
Is there somebody to assist you
in doing this, to guide you?
And maybe something about your personality
or your character.
Are you highly motivated?
Do you have a stick-to-itiveness?
If you say you're gonna do
something, do you get it done?
Do you have the flexibility of mind
to adapt to situations,
and if you run into problems,
are you going to be able
to overcome those problems
and see this project through?
It's often the case
that if you think about
three people who might write for you,
one of them really knows about
the work that you're doing
and why this is important,
but they don't know
you as well personally,
and maybe somebody else has
done field work with you
and maybe you reported to
them in a difficult situation
and they can talk about your character
and your ability to overcome obstacles,
but they're not in your field.
They don't have anything to do
with the kind of work you're doing.
Collectively they can give a
360 view of you as an applicant
and that's really what
you want to think about
if you're trying to decide
who should be writing for you.
I said earlier that the
second most important thing
for you to do was to understand
the goals of the agency.
It's also important for your referees
to understand the goals of the agency
and to make sure that their letters
are tailored to those goals.
I had a student come to me some years ago.
He was applying to the NSF and he said,
"One of my recommenders said,
they read my proposal and they said,
'Oh, take out all the stuff about
the outreach that you've been doing
and your teaching experience.
The NSF doesn't care about that.
They just want to see the science.'"
It's true that the science is important
and they're not going to fund a project
if they're not excited about the science,
but if all you have is good science,
that's good enough for
an honorable mention.
It's not gonna get you the NSF fellowship
because there is this
huge outreach component.
There's the scientific literacy component
to the NSF's mission.
You have to have good science
and you also have to show
that you're willing to go out
and share your science
with non-scientists.
They're both equally important
parts of the application.
If the funding agency has an
FAQ that you can print out
or if you can type up a cheat sheet
for the referees and say,
"These are the things that are important
to this funding agency.
This is what they're looking for,"
and ask them to tailor
their letter to those needs,
it just reinforces the idea
that this agency has a reason
for providing the funding.
We're trying to speak to those reasons.
In some cases you may be required
to submit a budget with your application.
I don't have a whole
lot to say about that.
Everybody's going to be
a little bit different.
Just a few tips I would
say is, first of all,
before you write up your budget,
be aware of what the
agency is willing to fund.
They may say, "We'll fund stipend
and travel expenses and health insurance,
but we don't fund tuition
and we don't fund research expenses."
That said, they may want
a comprehensive budget.
They may want to know the total cost
of what it is you're trying to do,
even though they're only
willing to fund a portion of it,
or they only want you to submit a budget
for the parts that
they're willing to fund.
Just know what their rules are
and make sure that
whatever it is you provide
speaks to that,
and don't be afraid to ask for help
from people in your department.
Others have done this before,
so don't feel like you're
entirely on your own
trying to put together a budget.
When you do the budgeting,
it's this sort of push-pull between
how much should I ask for,
is this gonna be enough,
I don't want to ask too much.
You certainly don't
want to pad the budget.
If the agency is looking
at three applications,
they say, "Well, this
person's asking for 10,000
and this person's asking for 5,000,
this person's asking for 4,000.
We like all three projects equally.
We can fund this one or
we can fund these two."
They might go for the
two, but at the same time,
you also want to make sure
you ask for what you need.
There's no point in submitting a proposal
if you know it's gonna cost $500 a month
to rent an apartment in
the place that you're going
and you only ask for $200 a month.
Unless you have another plan
for coming up with the other 300,
you're not gonna have a place to live.
Make sure you ask for what you need,
try not to ask for more
than what you need,
and use the people around
you who have done this before
to get some feedback about what they will
and about what they've done
and what they think is appropriate.
It's also useful to know whether
the agency will allow you
to seek additional funding
if they support you.
In some cases, Fulbright's
a good example of this,
they'll say that, "We're
giving you a stipend
and we're giving you a travel budget,
so we expect you not
to be getting a stipend
or travel support from other sources.
On the other hand, we're not
paying any research expenses,
so if you can find somebody else
who's willing to fund
the research expenses,
that's perfectly fine."
There are other agencies that
they're giving you a small fellowship.
It's $5,000 in stipend.
They know this isn't enough.
They expect you to go
out and get other awards
and it might even be helpful in that case
to say in the application,
"These are the other places
that I'm reaching out to
to try to get funding,"
but if you said that your total
budget is gonna be $50,000,
that's what you need to get this done
and you're applying to
this agency for $10,000,
they may say, "Well, this is
fine, we're excited by this,
but we want to know where he's
getting the other 40,000 from
before we commit our money
'cause 10,000 isn't
going to allow him or her
to do what he or she needs to do."
Again, you have to read the guidelines
and see what they say
and then try to tailor the application
to what they've asked for.
Just a couple of tips.
It's useful to keep transcripts handy,
to keep your CV up to date.
I find that when you're
applying for these things,
it's always just a lot easier to do
if the supporting
materials are ready to go,
if all you really need to
do is write the proposal
and then slip everything else in,
and again, read the rules.
Don't just rely on what
other people have told you
or what you think you
know about the agency.
There's gonna be some sort
of a call for applications.
There'll be a solicitation document.
Read the instructions.
Read them carefully.
Do they want a CV?
Do they want you to enter
all of this information
into an online form field?
They've asked for transcripts.
Do they have to be official transcripts?
Will unofficial transcripts do?
What happens if you can only
obtain electronic transcripts?
How do they handle that?
If this is one of those grants
where they do have some
short answer essays,
they're asking specific questions,
don't feel like you need to
repeat what's in the essays
in the statements.
You can use your space wisely
and if you've got something in one place,
use the other space to
talk about other things.
Certainly be aware of
application deadlines.
Most of them are pretty solid.
Most places will shut
down their applications
at the deadline so you
can't submit things late,
and remember that you don't have
full control over everything.
If you've requested transcripts
or you've requested
letters of recommendation,
you can tell people when
these things are due,
but they're gonna work
on their own timetables.
You want to make sure you let
people know well in advance.
Make sure they know
what the deadlines are.
Don't just tell them, "This
is due on October 30th."
Make sure they know this is
due at noon on October 30th,
at five o'clock on October 30th,
so they're not thinking
it's a midnight deadline
and they try to submit it and find out
that they can't get in,
and silly stuff.
I've seen so many students get caught up
with they've submitted something,
but they've used the wrong font
or they violated the guidelines
on margins or something.
Again, just read the instructions.
Make sure you know what
they're looking for
and make sure you conform
to whatever their
application guidelines are.
Just a few final thoughts
and then we'll open this up for questions.
It's not always the case,
but it's often the case
that if you've submitted
the proposal,
once they give you an answer,
they may give you feedback,
that you may get comments.
You may get a review of your application.
If you do, make use of it.
Read what they have to say.
If you didn't get funded,
feel free to rewrite
and respond to the critiques
that they've provided
and then resubmit.
I've seen, even at the faculty level,
I saw a grant a few months
ago, the agency said,
"We think that this proposal is too large.
We think it would benefit
from being more focused
on a smaller number of faculty,"
in a sort of a sub-field
within this larger field,
and they resubmitted the grant
and they basically had
a long explanation about
how the funding agency was wrong
and why it needed to be a larger grant.
Certainly they're within
their rights to do that,
but I don't think that
was a very wise approach.
If the funding agency had said,
"We liked what you submitted.
We're willing to fund this
but not willing to fund that,"
don't come back and try
to get that funded again.
Respond to what they've had to say.
Don't ignore the small awards.
There's a lot of grants out there,
the 25, 30, $35,000
fellowships and so forth
or travel awards and those
are great if you can get them,
but the small grants help too.
Somebody who can cobble
together enough small awards
has the equivalent of a large award,
and again, like I said at the beginning,
funding begets funding.
If somebody sees that you're out there
and you're applying for this
and that and the other thing
and you've been successful here
and you've been successful there,
it greases the wheels.
You're more likely to get
that big award down the road
if you have a couple of
small awards to your name.
We had a student here
a few years ago from,
I forget exactly, it was
a Scandinavian country,
and I think he fully funded
in two years of his education.
I don't think any of the awards he had
were worth more than $8,000,
but he had four or five of them,
and together, they pulled a full stipend.
It was really pretty
impressive, (laughing)
and again, just going back to
what I said at the beginning,
you should be proactive
and you should be applying for these now,
not after you get out of Yale
and suddenly you need the external support
and you don't have the backstop.
You do not want the first
application that you send in
to be the one that if it's not funded,
you can't do the work that you want to do.
Please, if you're looking at the support
that Yale's giving you and you're saying,
"Oh, there's all this money
from the MacMillan Center
and I got this stipend support.
I don't really need to be applying,"
this is just a great
time to get the practice.
You may be successful. You may not be.
If you're not,
you can still go out and
do what you need to do
because we do have other forms of support,
but the first grant is always the hardest.
They get easier to write.
The more you get, the
easier they get to get more.
Take advantage now of the sort
of safety net that you have
and please, please go
out and look for these.
I'll stop here.
If there are any questions,
I'll be happy to answer them,
and I have contact information here.
Please feel free to contact me later
if you're applying for something
and you have more specific questions
than might be appropriate in this setting.
- Thank you so much, Dean Harper-Mangels.
This has been great and just
what we were hoping for.
If any attendees do have questions
that you've not yet
submitted in the Q and A,
please feel free to type
those into the Q and A
and we'll do our best to get
them asked and answered here.
We do have some questions already.
They range from the particular
to the more general,
but let me just start with this one
since it's chronologically
first in some sense.
One person asks, "Is your
first year in graduate school
too early to start applying
for grants and fellowships?"
What's your opinion on that?
- Let me, I'm gonna stop the share,
but I'll put it back up at the end
if anybody still needs
my contact information.
I think it's never too
early to start applying.
Of course, it depends on,
everybody comes into graduate
school in a different place.
Some people already know
what they want to do
for their dissertation
and they know exactly
why they've come here
and who they want to work
with, and that's great,
and other people have general ideas,
but they're gonna spend the
first two years kicking around
and taking classes and going to seminars
and trying to figure out
where their passion lies.
What I would say is,
and just as we have a lot of students
who are in different places,
the fellowships are all
in different places.
There are some fellowships
that are very specific,
they support very specific types of work,
and there are others that
are very much more general,
that are really to support students
who one day will be
experts in their field,
but they're not necessarily designed
to support a specific course of study.
The NSF Graduate Research Fellowship
is a great example of this
and I think a lot of
people don't understand
that they don't just fund
the natural sciences,
they fund the social sciences as well,
and you write a proposal for the NSF
and they're evaluating that proposal.
They want you to propose something
that is interesting and innovative,
that you have a plan for doing,
but largely what they're doing
is evaluating your ability
to come up with a project.
They're evaluating your
ability to design a study
and go out and conduct that work.
They don't necessarily expect
you to do this specific study.
In fact, a lot of the people
who are applying for this
are actually college seniors
who at the time they're
submitting the application
don't actually know
where they're going to be
in graduate school yet.
Something like that,
and I should say there
are a few others like that
where you really have to apply
in your first or second year.
They're intended to be early-year awards.
I've encouraged students
to look for those,
but obviously as you move on,
as you move into your
third and fourth year,
you've written a prospectus,
you have a defined dissertation,
then you're going to be applying
for different types of grants
that are much more specific
and much more utilitarian.
We're supporting work in this field
where we give you travel money
so you can go to this country
and gather the data you
need for your dissertation.
Just understand that there's a wide range
of grants out there,
and so while the types of
things that you will look at
will change as you transition
to graduate school,
it's never too soon to start looking.
- I think you just
anticipated or maybe answered
this other question that
we received which is,
have you ever seen people
apply to grants and fellowships
that end up changing
their career trajectories,
not just allowing them to do
what they thought they were going to do
at the moment that they applied
to that grant or fellowship?
- Yeah, I think, especially
with a lot of the travel grants.
I see this all the time
with Fulbright fellows.
They propose to do X and
they get funded to do X
and they go to whatever
country they're going to do,
and while they're there,
they just have this amazing experience
and they're either turned
on to other resources
that they weren't aware of
or they run into problems
that they weren't expecting
and they need to shift gears,
and by the time they come back,
their research has gone
in a completely different
but totally exciting direction,
and so, yeah,
they can really be
transformative in that sense.
Obviously doesn't happen to everybody.
Some people just go and do
what they said they were going to do,
and that's fine too, but yeah,
it's not at all uncommon
for people to find their,
the process of doing the research
takes them in a very different direction
than they thought they were
going in when they started.
- That's great.
I have some mechanical questions for ya
that have popped up here as well.
You mentioned a cheat
sheet for recommenders
at one point in your talk,
which was really very helpful.
One of the questions here
is about how an applicant,
a student can help their
advisor to best support them
in the application process.
For example, by writing the strongest
letter of recommendation that
the recommender can write.
The question that, for example,
should I be providing a set of documents
to my recommenders in
advance that describe things
like my personality, my
project, my motivation?
Beyond the FAQ,
how should I describe the fellowship
or grant opportunity to my recommenders?
Any further thoughts
about what cheat sheets
or document packets for
recommenders might look like?
- Yeah, that's great.
I would say that there are two things
that would be very helpful
to your recommenders.
The first is just understanding
the goals of the agency.
What are they looking for?
And it may be that there's
just a page you can print out
from the agency itself that
says these are our goals
or there's an FAQ or something, or if not,
if you've read their materials
and you don't have something easy
that you can point them to,
then you can type something up and say,
"This is what this agency is supporting.
These are the sorts of
things that they said
they were looking for in an application.
These are the points I've tried
to hit on in my proposal,"
and then the second part of that is
just your personal
qualities, and I would say,
I don't know that I would give an advisor
a cheat sheet that says
this is my personality
or something along those
lines, but certainly,
I talked about some of
those tangible examples
that you might put into
a personal statement
and if you want to tell them,
"These are some of the
things that I have done
that I think makes me
qualified to do this.
These are some of the things
and these experiences that I've had
that I think will be of
interest to this agency
and that I intend to
promote in my essays,"
to the degree that you
feel comfortable doing so,
please try to speak to
these in your letter.
- That's great.
You gave some wonderful advice about
getting feedback on the personal statement
or other parts of the
application that'll be submitted,
and one person asks, they say,
"I worry that I'm getting
the wrong kind of feedback
on my application.
When I speak to my peers in my department
or my academic advisors,
I feel like they continue
to push me to be narrow
and more specific.
How should I balance that sort of feedback
from experts and peers,
some of whom, of course,
who never received a
grant like this before,
with the kind of feedback
I can receive from,
for example, the Graduate Writing Lab?"
- Yeah, that's tricky.
Part of the process
you're in now as a student
and becoming a full-fledged
academic is sort of,
it's that transition from being a student
to being the master.
It's sort of knowing when
you have to take the advice
that's being given to you
by people who are older
and more experienced and more credentialed
and when it's time to stand up and say,
"No, I actually know more
about this than you do,
and I appreciate your advice,
but we're going my way with it."
This is part of that process,
and I place great deference on
what the faculty have to say
and the advice that they give,
but I've also seen that they don't know
everything about everything,
and I gave that one
example of the professor
who was writing for the
NSF applicant who said,
"Oh yeah, take out all the stuff about
your activities outside of the lab.
They don't care about that."
No, they really do care about that
and taking that out would've
been a huge mistake.
What you need to weigh
is the degree to which,
is the advice you're getting
simply a matter of personal preference
or is it really going against
what you know the agency is looking for?
And if it's really going against
what the agency is looking for,
then you have to go against that advice.
You have to go your own way and say,
"No, this is what the
agency is looking for."
The people who work in the field,
they know all the nuances about the field
and if they were reviewing
an application in the field,
they would expect you to be knowledgeable
about those nuances,
but if you know that this is being read
by people who are not
experts in the field,
then you need to step up a level
and you really need to give
them the bigger picture
and understand that the nuances
that are so important to you
and to your advisor and to
other people in your circle
are going to be lost on people
who are actually making
these funding decisions,
but it's hard.
There's no easy answer to that.
You're going to get conflicting advice
and part of becoming a professional is
evaluating that advice and saying,
"Yeah, in this circumstance,
this is good advice.
This is bad advice. This
is what I'm going to do."
- I think I have another question
for which there's not
necessarily an easy answer.
(Robert and Steve laughing)
It's a question about tone
and about selling oneself
or trumpeting oneself.
Question is, "I'm worried about coming off
as overly confident in my applications,
which is funny because I don't
feel altogether confident
about my work.
How do I think about striking a balance
between modesty on the
one hand," parentheses,
"I am still learning,
and mastery on the other,
as I am an emerging professional
and you should give me money."
- That's a great question.
I would say, obviously, I
don't want to oversell this,
but this is not the time to be humble.
You are a developing
professional in this field.
You are becoming a knowledge
expert on your subject
and you want to promote yourself as such.
There are certain grants and
I have a lot of experience
working with Fulbright fellows,
so I keep coming back to that.
One of the things that
Fulbright wants to know
is that people are adaptable.
They understand that if
you're going to Tanzania
to do some research and
there's civil strife there
and there's a disease outbreak,
you might not be able to do
what you've proposed to
do once you get there
and situation's unpredictable.
They understand that things
can change very suddenly.
They want to know that the people
that they're sending overseas
are going to be able to
deal with that situation
and you're not going
to just suddenly become
paralyzed and ineffective.
For a proposal like that,
it's perfectly fine to say,
"This is what I wanna do.
These are the resources I need.
This is what I expect to
be able to accomplish.
I'm aware of these situations
and aware that there may be circumstances
that could prevent this from happening.
Should that happen,
here's some of the directions
that I could possibly go in."
That's one level at which you
might just acknowledge that,
yeah, I've got these great plans,
but sometimes when the
rubber hits the road,
plans fall through and
I've got ideas about
how I would adapt to
that and run with that.
What you don't want to
do is certainly say,
"Well, here's what I want to do.
I'm not sure if I really have
the expertise to do this,"
or, "I'm not sure if I'm good
enough to get this done."
If you're not sure, then they're not sure
and they're not going to fund you.
That's the end of it.
To the degree that you're
proposing to do things
where you really don't have expertise,
so I'll give you a good example of this.
I had a student some years back,
again, applying for a Fulbright.
She was an engineer.
She wanted to go to Indonesia
and she was interested in water filtration
and delivery of clean
water to rural communities.
Part of her project was
actually working in a lab
at the university there studying
water filtration systems
and thinking about ways
to make them cheaper,
more affordable so they
could be mass-produced
and got them out to the
public, and as an engineer,
she was well-qualified to do that work.
There was a second
component to her proposal
in which she was going to do
a social science component.
She was going to go out
into the communities
and find out who was using
the water filtration systems
that were already available to them.
Who was using them, who wasn't using them,
what were the barriers to using them,
how effective were they,
how often were people
getting sick, and so forth.
She did not have a background
in conducting social science
research, and in fact,
she didn't have the local language
that might allow her to go out
into these rural communities.
She was fine working at the university,
but not necessarily in these communities
outside of the city,
but she had a great plan
because she was paired up
with an NGO that was
working in the country
that was interested in this project
and she was going to partner with them
to do the social science
component of the project.
She was able in her application to say,
"There's two parts to my project.
These are the skills I
have to carry out this one,
and that's solid.
These are the skills I
have to carry out the other
and they're a little more tenuous,
but here's the support that
I have to help me do that,"
and she was funded for this.
I think that if there's a real,
you don't want to be humble.
You don't want to be saying,
"Oh, I could probably do this.
Other people might be better at it."
Not the time to be humble,
but if there's a real
component to the application
where you think, "I don't
have the skills to do this yet
and anybody reading the
application is gonna see
that I don't have the
skills to do this yet,"
then you want to talk about
what kind of support do I have.
Maybe this grant doesn't start for a year
and so how am I going to get
the skills I need in the next year,
or what kind of support
am I getting from Yale,
or what kind of support am I getting
from the area where I'll
be conducting this research
that will allow me to
both develop my skills
and carry this out
despite the lack of
experience that I have?
- As you're talking, Robert,
it strikes me that you're, in a sense,
urging people to express confidence about
the problem that they're
looking to address
as being an important problem,
the questions that they're
bringing to that problem,
and their own ability to
address those questions.
There's also a piece of
this that seems to me
in which applicants are
trying to emphasize,
as you say, their flexibility,
or other ways to think about
this might be curiosity,
willingness to change course
if the answers come through
that they're not expecting,
and I do sometimes feel like
sometimes applicants make
too strong of an argument
that they know exactly
what the answers are
and they just need to go
out and find the evidence
to substantiate exactly what
they know to already be true.
Have you ever seen that
as a problem in anything,
any students you've worked with?
- Yeah, that comes up periodically.
They've already decided
what the conclusion is
before they've actually gathered the data
and they don't leave any wiggle room
for if I go out and find these sources
and it's not actually matching up
with what I think I'm going to find,
they don't allow for that
possibility in their brain space
and I think that can be a
real problem, and again,
it's hard to talk about this
in the abstract because, again,
every funding agency is
a little bit different.
Some of these grants
are funding the student.
They're funding your
development as a scholar,
and so that curiosity, that flexibility,
that idea that, "You know what?
This project might not work out,
but this person's going to
learn a lot in that process
and is going to be a better
scholar for it in the future."
That's great for some agencies,
and others, they want a deliverable.
"We're funding you to go out and get X
and this is why we're
giving you the money,
and if you can't get X,
then we're gonna give the
money to somebody else,"
and that's again one of
those things where you might,
one award might be more appropriate
for a second or third-year
student who's still developing
but isn't sure about everything,
whereas the other one might be good
for a fifth or sixth-year student
who's pretty far along in their research,
already has drawn their conclusions,
just needs to go out and
get some supporting data
or fill in some gaps somewhere
and it's much more
specific, detailed grant
than they might otherwise be applying for.
- That makes sense.
I have two more questions for you
and they're both pretty practical.
The first person asks, basically,
"How do I know what a
reasonable budget looks like
that isn't, quote, padded?
I'm not asking to spend the
night in a five-star hotel,
but do I have to say that I
will sleep in a one-star hotel?"
(Robert laughing)
- The best way to answer this, I'd say,
is that other people have probably gone
to wherever it is you're going
and had to provide a budget too,
and so it's a good idea to
just talk to other people
who have traveled and
see what kinds of budgets
they have proposed.
There's some resources online.
Some of the funding agencies, for example,
will have guidelines as
to what they will provide
for this or that or the other thing,
and if you say, "I'm going
to go to this country,
and yes, the program will provide
up to $500 a month for accommodations,
but I actually know
somebody in the country
and I won't need that.
I can pay them $100 for expenses and,"
the agency will appreciate the fact
that you're finding ways to save money,
but I would say, in terms
of knowing what to do,
just talk to other
people who have applied.
I think the MacMillan Center
is probably a great resource
for travel abroad, where they can say,
"This is what the living
expenses are in the country."
Your travel expenses,
go online and look at
a variety of airlines
and figure out what roundtrip
tickets are gonna cost
and try to pick the cheapest one
that doesn't involve you
flying in a cargo plane
with crates full of chickens.
You don't have to cut it to the bone
and have the cheapest budget
you can possibly find,
but they do expect you to
cut costs where you can,
but usually there are resources online
and certainly resources
at the university can say,
"Yes, living expenses in
this country for a traveler
would be between 300 and
700 a month," for example,
and so probably best then not
to come down on the $700 side.
You don't have to say 300.
You want to give yourself
a little room maybe,
but try to come in under
500 if that's the range,
but other people have done this before you
and have had experience
and had budgets approved
or had budgets cut,
and so there should be resources out there
to help you figure out what's appropriate.
- Great, thank you, and the last question,
the answer may be the same,
which is that there are other people
who can help you with this,
but maybe you have particular
thoughts about who.
The question is really about
CVs, and the person says,
"I'm not sure if my CV
is properly formatted
(Robert laughing)
or if it has
the right information on it. (laughing)
Do you have any suggestions about
how one should get feedback on their CV
to make sure that it's
professionally ready?"
- First of all, I will just say
that there's a lot of
different CVs out there.
There's different styles.
There's not necessarily
one right way to do it,
and I myself, when I was
younger and applying for jobs,
depending on the nature of
the job I was applying for,
would move things around on
my CV, which would either,
which would emphasize my research
or would emphasize my teaching
experience or what have you,
depending on the job I was applying for.
It's not a one size fits all,
but I think that the Office
for Career Strategies
is a great resource for,
if you contact them and
say you need some help,
you need somebody to look at your CV
and give you some feedback on that,
they have people there that
can help you with that.
- Great. Thank you so
much, Dean Harper-Mangels.
That's not the most extravagant
way to end this session.
I think that was rather kind of mundane,
but I think a really important advice
because I think it's
one of the many things
that so many applicants worry about
when they're making these applications,
and they're, as you well know,
many people are doing these applications
while they're very busy with other work,
and so trying to figure
out ways to explain
what people ought to be
doing and how is just so key,
and so thank you so much
for making such a compelling argument
for the importance of
making these applications.
I think you're absolutely right
that applying in these ways really is key
for people to learn how
to promote their own work
and that funding begets
funding, as you say,
and that for those reasons and others,
encouraging people in the greater
RITM network and elsewhere
to be looking for these opportunities,
I think, is incredibly beneficial,
even as it can be hard and difficult
in the course of one's regular,
very busy life as well.
- And I'll say,
it's the mundane aspects
of the application
that often people find daunting.
They know what they're doing,
they understand their research,
but then they find out
they have to pull in
all of these other pieces of information
and that gets a lot of people caught up.
I remember the first time,
when I worked at Northwestern,
before I came to Yale,
and my director came to me and he said,
"We're going to apply for an
institutional training grant,"
and these are large
multimillion-dollar awards
that fund multiple
faculty, multiple students.
The proposal itself, the
scientific component to it,
it was only 10 to 15 pages.
The entire proposal is about 200 pages
'cause suddenly you
need data about students
going back 10 years and
how many people came in
and where did they wind up going
and what's your training
program look like,
and that was really hard
to do the first time,
but I gotta tell you, by the
time we did the fifth one,
we had a process, we had
a lot of the data already,
and so once we had the intellectual
component put together,
then we could just slot in
all those mundane elements
and it got a lot easier to do.
This is one of the things where I say
it gets easier to write these
things as you go forward
because as you get used to
doing the mundane parts of it,
you can focus on the interesting
intellectual component
and then just add in all
of that mundane stuff
that needs to be part of the application
and it just gets so much easier over time.
- I really appreciate that,
and I think this is the kind of training
that we get too little of,
at least on our side of the university,
so thank you so much for your time today
and for giving us the
benefit of your skills.
I'm sure people will follow up with you,
and I know you've already shared
your email address with people
and so I would just add my voice
to encourage people to
write to you directly
if there's anything that they think
you might be able to help them with
or direct them elsewhere.
I think you've offered
yourself up as a resource,
so we really appreciate that.
- Yeah, please take advantage of me.
This is why I'm here.
If you have questions,
please get in touch.
- All right. Thank you, Rob.
Thank you, everybody.
- [Robert] My pleasure.
- Take care.